la chanson titre c'est une chanson sur
les handicapés j'en comprends pas
comment trouvez vous que je dise mettant
voile sinon on va pas se tromper c'est
pas un peu beaucoup donc savez
l'émission dollar tapissent les
handicapés n'ont rien eu un petit bout
je sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'on
passe un peu d'un extrême à l'autre voix
c'est à dire que les handicapés seraient
pendant des années personne s'en occuper
aujourd'hui on fait des émissions télé
après 10h30 on fait de tout mettre dans
l'autre sens c'est pas une chanson sur
les handicapés que vous lui fait en tout
cas c'est 1500 sur le handicap soit
pareil
voilà une carte ça peut leur donner tort
à plat lui quelqu'un qui est
un problème par bergerac in abonnés
ouais c'est un idéal que c'est une
question et c'est le regard des autres
sur lui ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup frappé et ça me frappe trop tôt
ça m'est arrivé trop de fois sur le
ventre le jean j'allais avec sa soeur tu
vas tu dis souvent dans tes chansons
pendant ce disque là d'ailleurs en
particulier je voudrais qu'il y ait plus
de tolérance est ce que c'est parce que
c'est pas angélistes de dire j'aurais
qu'elles sont non mais elle ne dépasse
pas un chanteur engagé mais dont un peu
dans le sens du poil finalement tu prend
pas beaucoup de risques parce que dire
au jour d'aujourd'hui qu'on peut plus de
tolérance est ce que finalement c'est
pas enfoncer une porte ouverte que de
dire que l'on laisse les gens sont
tolérants c'est pas dit qu'une banalité
au contraire est ce qu'on obtient des
résultats concrets avec ce discours un
peu néo humaniste un peu de charme en
dix ans d'un centre est est ce que les
os qui est capable il ya plus de
tolérance sks que les gens du terme en
devises mieux finalement même les
contres les artistes alors là je laisse
ma femme voilà moi mais en action avec
leur chanteur trois frontières qu'elles
sont les régimes pas ça bien résultats
changement d'abord de mentalité les
adultes vis-à-vis des jeunes je crois
que par exemple si on parle d'eux
c'est bob geldof par exemple du taux de
chô de gens je crois que la grande
réussite et ça c'est qu'on a ici les
artistes de la roque musique dans mon
entier ont réussi à dému l'image de ce
que pourrait être le monde ils ont créé
un modèle tu veux dire oui ils ont
montré si on avait envie de faire
quelque chose si on avait envie dire ça
c'était est insupportable vit dans un
monde que lui n'était que j'en ai
quelque chose c'était possible sachant
que ça on est dark ale autre chose qui
me choque chez toi c'est que daniel
balavoine
c'était sûrement un bon copain à toi à
mamie dont tu as accepté la critique ce
qui est bien quelqu'un qu'avait bon
coeur qu'ils aient des bonnes chansons
mais est ce qu'on peut en faire
aujourd'hui un maître à penser est ce
que c'est pas grave de faire de
balavoine needle vrai que ça m a foncé
avec moi là bas je parcours de balavoine
connu à la télévision tous à u2 et le
cas si tu veux comme si c'était un grand
non seulement parce que c'est pas
exagérer à faire ça du tout moi moi moi
j'aime bien ces chansons et touré bis
qui décrivait et j'ai envie de continuer
avec ces sessions sont c'est tout ça pas
plus loin car non pas toi faut pas
mélanger je voyais ça fait 1 trouve
vraiment que beaucoup de gens font ces
mélanges et quelqu'un qui écrit les
chansons avec un maître à penser c'est à
dire si il écrit les chansons qui nous
plaisent ça veut dire qu'il va avoir une
solution sur tout et ça je crois que
pour vraiment à mélanger soir est ce
qu'au fond cas pas un désir sincère de
faire du bien comme ton père qui a
inventé la grève durera qu'un mec bon
les faits du bien à l'humanité c'est
évident est-ce que tu changeras du mien
c'est vrai je crois que quand on est
médecin fait du bien on peut trouver des
trucs vous vérifiez le pape a finalement
le désir refoulé de faire du bien mais
je crois que ma faim disque puisse faire
ni bien sûr les juges contre x alors là
c'est vraiment c'est jaurès un besoin il
devait affronter rim alors bon saussines
aurélien tels que vous fallu me est ce
que t'as pas été déçus par la politique
finalement parce que c'est quand même
bon petit assoupi mitterrand 88 qui
allait souvent à l'elysée il ya toujours
pas de chaises musicales monseur michel
berger s'est vivement un l a pas été un
peu trahi non mais moi les limites de la
politique je trouverais existe profonde
et même équipe a quand il parle du seuil
de tolérance par exemple il était rentré
déçu elle a quand même non non mais moi
je suis incapable d'être d'accord avec
les cassures tout simplement on l'a
quand on a un choix à faire on appelle
cela la met
c'est vrai cachet musical on est environ
sur la table a toujours pas d'accord je
crois encore en dieu ont pas su l'elysée
dit l'elysée
comme les gens disent moi je trouve ça
assez bon président et si je compare ce
qu'il veut avec
avec les autres finalement je crois que
c'est un mais six mois je peux me
tromper j'ai l'impression que quelqu'un
qui a été sensible à les choses
justement il manie et ovidiu est-ce que
tu y crois il ya une expression will i
am qui sont formidables
j'espère qu'il a une bonne raison je
trouve c'est vrai respect de nos raisons
s'il existe parce qu'il ya des choses
qui sont maintenant qu'ils paraissent
pas le droit